good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
thursday
we're cruising along we're moving right
along okay yeah tuesday and wednesday
we're super busy days
which actually was helpful because then
you just like woke up after the
whirlwind
and now it's thursday which means
tomorrow's friday so
the week is moving at a pleasant pace
yeah it is i'm in this like annoying
spot
within the week where because i had gma
and i had like my hair and makeup done
i'm off on my hair washing schedule and
this is i'm not gonna lie is one wash
for the whole week because
no sorry whatever i usually would have
washed my hair last night
but i didn't because i got a fresh blood
on tuesday like what am i doing
but now it's like i wish i could make
this blowout last one more day till
tomorrow but it's starting to smell
you could make it last one more day if
you just do it in an updo or something
or a bun or a pony something fun
use those oils to your advantage those
natural oils
yeah hi i'm claudia i just feel like
everything's changed for you since the
book came out
so true like and you're even wearing an
updo on the cover of the book and i just
feel like it's a sign that you can start
wearing your hair up
it's a sign that changes is on the
horizon yeah i think that it is and so
if there was ever a time for you to go
for a low bun
i think it's tomorrow maybe i'll see the
reason why i don't wear my hair up
in public is just because i suffer from
a very very serious illness called
fat face syndrome and it's devastating
and
super super contagious it's in some
countries it's called fat fotch
um and i just find that a up do whether
it's low or high really accentuates some
of the symptoms that come along with fat
face syndrome i think that you're
you're missing it because i too have a
round face but when i do an updo like
here i have my solo camera on
you pull your face like so tight that
you actually make your face
look like i mean i'll think about it
it's just it's a lot for me to kind of
at least with the book cover i knew that
photoshop was on my side
i do have something on my side on this
show i actually always strategically
place the microphone
to cover my double chin sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't but it's nice
to have that layer of security
and you also have the good side which i
generously gave you four years ago yeah
that's your good side
yes and it's also my good side oh but i
took the bad side for you that's super
generous yeah
thank you you're welcome hope everyone's
having an amazing day we have a great
show for you guys
jackie and i spoiler alert are a little
behind
on some of our bravo this week on
everything we didn't watch last night we
didn't watch the night before we have no
tv recap for you today
i've been so exhausted like we were up
last night doing the redheads like
it's just been a crazy week obviously
with the release of my critically
acclaimed novel
um so we're going to get back on track
next week so
just feel free to take the week off you
guys i'm just i could not be bothered
with the
house i literally got home so late last
night we were recording redheads it's
our longest episode ever and i think our
best it was so much fun to have you
join the girls i'm in the process of
editing it still so it will be up later
today because there's just like so much
so many mics so many voices so there's
actually a lot of audio editing that is
going into it
and it will be up today i'm really
excited for everyone to hear it
was really fun so now that you have
experienced like
the sensation of being a part of the
redheads community like do you
understand what i've been talking about
this whole time 100
i mean the podcast was so fun my
favorite part was when we went to dinner
afterwards because i love dinner
but it was fun to just like chat yeah
but i'd
have fun talking about myself in my book
like i could literally talk to a wall
while so i was on the bobby bone show
this morning if anyone caught it it was
fabulous
so exciting so well back to the ready
yeah sorry i choose to get my little
promo in there no i know but
it is just like fun to read a book and
then have people to talk about it with
and of course it's always fun to talk
about your book but like you know the
feeling when you finish all those books
over vacation and it's like
you learn new stuff about the book or
like hearing what other people took away
from it or like
i'm sure it was nice for you to listen
to your friends and family like
hear what stood out to them about your
book i only think like i would fully
become a redhead but i do think that it
would pose a problem for you and the
rest of the gals
because you know we're a two-person show
and i literally steamroll over you
like i just can't help but talk over you
finish your sentences like incorrectly
like i just have all these terrible
habits that i really am working on i'm
very well aware
and i just think it would be four times
worse with four hosts
five hosts four other hosts besides yeah
oh yeah
no for sure we're definitely an ensemble
crew and
when we do a normal episode we really
have a rhythm to us
in terms of how we talk and try not to
talk over each other but i thought that
we did a great job yesterday yeah i just
feel like i shouldn't personally like
[ __ ] with the rhythm
got it got it well also it's just a big
month for the redheads because
our regular scheduled episode also drops
next week where we're reading how to
fail at flirting by denise williams and
so many people are absolutely loving
them well i like it yeah it's like
rom-com
vibe you know i haven't read a book that
wasn't my own since
our vacation over holiday season
and i'm really getting the itch to read
so i think i need to go on vacation
i'm getting the industry too i think you
do need to go i think we got to just hit
up you know a beach town a local beach
town would love to just so i can relax
and read
i would i would absolutely love that i
won't stop you okay from taking so many
so yes
redheads is out and anything else i have
to promote oh taylor strecker today's
thursday
my episode with taylor strecker um
should be out now
i'm not sure what time she goes live but
it should be out
very exciting so when you're done with
this you have a whole day's worth of
content that you can listen to
and we have a patreon episode uh episode
going up today i'm just waiting for your
approval yes no i'm literally have been
so
i know it's been a crazy week and busy
that i have not had time to watch your
vlog but i'm
so excited too oh and right after
today's episode jackie and i
are recording an interview for
tomorrow's episode with someone i think
you would never expect to grace the
presence of the toast and i cannot wait
for everyone to find out yeah truly an
icon a hosting icon
yes it's going to be hilarious i cannot
wait for you guys to hear that
but i think that it's time to just get
right into it yes we actually have a lot
to do today
so we do like post show yes without
further ado
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and you know what i have a major medical
update
tell us my rdh is cured how so
because bruce just brings me so much joy
there's nothing to be remiss devastated
or heartbroken about i feel you
today's episode is brought to you by
bruce the electric toothbrush that
literally everyone
needs in their lives the bruce why is it
special
it is first of all one of the best
electric toothbrushes i've ever used and
the most reasonably priced a lot of them
on the market can cost
over 200 dollars which for a toothbrush
is just kind of unnecessary
but bruce is just as good as the others
but is so reasonably priced
and it's fabulous looking it's very
sleek i have it in pink it looks great
on your counter
the magnetic charging station is very
elon musk
it's just everything of the sort and it
gets the job done so well
the brush itself has six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience
the battery life lasts four weeks with
the magnetic charging stand and the
compact travel case
which is great because if you want to
travel with it and you're not traveling
for more than four weeks you don't need
to bring the charger so
that's sickening now they also offer a
subscription program so you don't have
to ever forget
to change your brush head again because
bruce will ship you a new replacement
head every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down
head um the design is so fabulous so
modern so aesthetically pleasing and it
comes in trend driven seasonal colors
and it looks great on your bathroom
counter if you want to get 15 off your
brush toothbrush kit and refill plan
when you use promo code toast bruce dot
com
again to get the 15 off you got to go to
bruce.com which is br
uush.com and the promo code is toast for
15
off check it out it is my favorite
product
ever ever i use it twice a day
i use it twice a day when i remember but
without fail always once a day but
sometimes the nighttime like i'm just
so lazy to get out of bed that's crazy
is it
like how often would you say how many
times a week do you brush at night
five or six okay fine like just if i'm
if i'm drinking like i totally forgot
and some nights like are just harder
than others to like get from the bed
back to the bathroom
yeah you like didn't plan it out right
yeah no because like what there's a
certain moment when you get into bed for
the night where it's over like there's
nothing else happening and if you
haven't washed your face and brush your
teeth by then like it's
not gonna have to wait till the next
night to do your skincare routine i feel
that
okay first story big news of the day
halsey announces that she is pregnant
she's expecting her first baby with alev
aiden
i didn't even know like she had a
boyfriend i thought she was still with
evan peters i know i guess we hadn't
gotten an update in a while
and now she is with dating a
screenwriter alev on wednesday
she took her instagram to announce that
she's expecting her first child in a
series of pictures
that she captioned surprise she can be
seen cradling her baby bump she
captioned the photo
along with a milk bottle rainbow and
angel emoji
in the comments on her post olive wrote
quote heart so phil
i love you sweetness after seeing the
cute note she replied i love you
and i love this mini human already this
is so cute i'm just like genuinely
surprised like i don't
i don't find myself getting shook
anymore by celebrity news like they're
so predictable everything they do
but i just didn't see this happening for
halsey because i didn't even know that
she had a boyfriend and i'm so happy for
her
i feel like she has been through like a
great deal of things emotionally when it
comes to relationships
and this feels like a happy ending for
her and i'm so thrilled about it not two
jinx you know an exciting beginning
yes so yeah i was surprised as well and
i'm i'm very very happy for her
and the photo shoot was like sickeningly
very casey muskrates you know it's
really hard to like
achieve a new type of pregnancy
announcement yeah that isn't like
sponsored by clear blue
yeah and so this is just like so
artistically well done
and pliny which we love to see adore
love and she's a stunning photo yeah i'm
really really happy for over the last
few years i have
um started to just like garner enormous
respect for halsey like
every time she speaks out on something
like i always agree with her she's just
like a very smart girl
and i love her music and i love how much
she loves like country music and she's
always like
she loves all the people that i love
because she loves taylor swift and
kelsey ballerini like
i just love halsey yeah me too and
when someone posted this in the toast
after dark facebook group like people
were like oh my god so shook in the
comments
and somebody commented something so
funny that i never really thought of
this girl was like
today is the day that i realized that
it's halsey not hasley
that's really shocking i didn't know
that there was confusion i wonder if
there's like a whole community of people
who think it has like
i don't think so i think it's like same
amount of people who thought rascal
flatts was a name
those by the way those people are
showing up more and more
there are a lot of us okay that's insane
there are a lot of us
and we will not be embarrassed and
ridiculed by people like you
with intellectual superiority oh i
didn't know rascal was the name good for
you not all of us went to harvard
but not for me but not for me
i [ __ ] love that sound i just love
tick-tock references in everyday life
you know i know and for me
i only have a few in my repertoire
because
i don't watch tick tock so it has to
like really
trickle down to me to mainstream society
but not
for me i can't believe you don't watch
tick tocks like you literally must have
so much free time
no but i'm still so booked and busy no
if i didn't have tick tocks like i
literally would be elon musk
i'm just it's really holding me back
because it's hours upon
hours so what was your excuse for not
being elon musk before tick tock
oh i was building
with all of her time in the book yes
girl with no job
my memoirs out it's girl no job.com
slash book
audiobook versions are available people
are loving the audiobook and also the
ebook and hardcover have
the little photos inside which is very
exciting people are loving the photos as
well
and i don't know i'm just um i'm not as
thirsty anymore because like so many
people have gotten the book and like
it's actually crazy
my instagram has never been more popping
like i wish it was like this all the
time it's so exciting like so much
positivity
um and i'm gonna go to a couple more
book stores in the city today uh so
look at my instagram stories cause i'm
gonna hit uh barnes noble and tribeca
and then a couple local bookstores love
it so check it out are you ready for our
next story
sure queen elizabeth has no plans to
step down to allow prince charles to
take the crown
of course so she is turning 95 in april
and a few months ago oh
[ __ ] a few months ago we reported that
some people were saying that when she
turns 95 she's stepping down
got it now insiders are saying she will
be doing nothing of the sort
she said the insider said neither her
physical nor her mental health are
waning
a close source to the monarch adds that
she is well
and in good fettle well the thing is is
that not only is queen
elizabeth not the type to give up before
she dies
if she was like she's not giving charles
any more years like
everyone knows he's like useless and
like maybe if it was william she would
like feel comfortable and she'd be like
you know what i can
you know live out the rest of my life
peacefully but charles she is going
she's in no rush to hand you to
charlotte
you are going to have to pull the
monarchy from her cold dead fingers
before charles becomes a monarch
yeah and so i feel like when we reported
the story saying that she was going to
step down like we didn't think that that
was gonna happen and
i hope that that was our take on it
because now still not confirmed because
these are all just like sources
competing with one another
but that this is the prevailing news
right now is very heartwarming i'm not
ready to see her go
in any way shape or form no no not at
all i'm not ready for and i'm usually
very pro
change like i i like to shake things up
some people are anti i'm very pro change
i'm not ready for a new monarch and i
don't even [ __ ] live in england like
i am not ready i actually went down like
such a rabbit hole yesterday because i
was on the kensington royal instagram
because they were putting out some
premium [ __ ] content
for holocaust remembrance day and i did
not see any [ __ ] people on instagram
influencers celebrities nobody talking
about holocaust remembrance day
and kate uh middleton got on a zoom with
two holocaust survivors who met in
auschwitz like
it was so premium and so special and i
stand
more than ever yes we have no choice but
to stand harder than ever i saw exactly
what you saw and had the exact same
thought that like kensington
palace is like turning out the most
premium holocaust remember and say well
everyone else is remaining silent no
literally i was so disappointed yeah but
also we forgot to mention it on the
toast yesterday but i was so unwell
but i posted about it on instagram yes
um
and i did the yacht hashem um like
remember like that's such a nice thing
we explain to people what it is so yad
vashem is like the world's holocaust
museum they're like the biggest
database of holocaust information they
connect people who lost their families
like still to this day like
there's not a full record of every six
million people because they were buried
in mass graves like
throwed thrown into the ground and like
not given a proper burial so
there's so much like anonymity when it
comes to the holocaust and yad vashem a
bunch
with a bunch of other organizations is
um kind of the leading institution they
have a museum in washington dc and in
israel and if you've ever been then you
know it is
so powerful so powerful and they're just
constantly like doing the most like
collecting information
connecting people you know to their
parents who like they literally lost
in in a ghetto and so they have this
thing online which is really cool where
you submit your name and they kind of
assign you to a survivor who's like
story was never told
and it's like children it's mothers it's
crazy and it's becoming like the world's
largest database
and so you just put in your name and
they give you uh a person and i got a
fabulous woman who i learned all about
wow it's all on their instagram yeah
check it out it's a really great
program and like a way to remember the
people who are lost and if museums ever
open like i
if you're ever in washington dc or
israel like i encourage you
it is so so amazing yeah truly
so back to the queen she's just a
literal queen
and no one else can do it like she can
no and just like if she were still
roaming this earth and she wasn't the
queen it just would be so unacceptable
no i agree i
it's just so crazy to me that like these
people are 95. how old is prince edward
because he's no what's his name not
edward phil phillip he's older than her
yeah i i don't i want to say he's like
99. yeah he's not in his hundreds yet
when you see him you're like oh this man
is a skeleton like he's
so old and i just didn't know people
lived to be that old and it's like are
they living to be that old because
they're just like
blessed or because they have some
special science that nobody else has in
the monarchy
both i think i think they have the
world's best medical care and i think
that they also have
strong jeans it's just crazy like
i've never met someone older than like
80. yeah crazy crazy so
that's your little royal update for the
day i love royal updates
me too you know who's been real quiet
megan and harry they have been
yeah hmm i wonder well how's their
podcast going anyone here
i haven't heard anything me neither
there's so much excitement around it
i don't know let's check it out okay
next story something that we spoke about
earlier this week but matt
james is responding to his friend body
shaming victoria larson
good i'm so glad that's not what i'm
about
he was on thursday's episode today's
episode of the real talk show saying
that it
is never something that i condone or
stand for he said it's just a reminder
that you need to be smart about the
people you surround yourself with
and those moments when you're in sports
and people are trying to say things
to throw you throw things off your game
it's sad that someone would think saying
something like that about a woman that i
was dating would deter me from what i
was trying to do
he continues who is he to comment on
someone's body it's such a low blow for
any man to try and take a dig at
something like that
that's not my character and that's not
what i'm about it's a shame that that's
even
associated with what was going on i
apologize on his behalf i don't know if
you'll get it from him but that's not
not something i support or stand for i
don't need an apology from this man who
i've never heard of
i want an apology from like tyler and
matt for laughing yeah
i love that the women of the reel asked
him this question and i um
actually i'm gonna watch this because i
haven't seen the interview yet but it
was so
disappointing like yeah i was so and you
know i'm like we live in very like
sensitive times where everyone is like
offended and i really pride myself on
like you cannot offend me like
but this actually like deeply offended
me because i have been that girl like
i have overheard someone talking about
my body and it feels
[ __ ] horrible like you'll never
forget where you are when you like heard
someone call you fat behind your back
for the first time and they like
didn't think that you heard them but you
did and like this was
so disappointing like so upsetting and i
don't even like victoria because she's
like the worst but now they're out here
making her into the hero
yeah into the queen
yeah so i'm glad that he addressed it
i'm glad that they asked about it but
yeah i
agree with you it was really
disappointing yeah
that was just like gross yeah and like
that guy
yeah oh oh sorry and to make matters
worse like who the hell are you
yeah who the hell are you okay
next up the real housewives of new
jersey season 11 taglines are
here i saw and they they can okay you go
theresa they say it's never too late to
start over
i say starting over never tasted so good
um i don't get that maybe like tasty we
have a cookbook coming
maybe but just i'm saying in terms of
logic in the line like
you don't taste a new start yeah no and
it's like there wasn't a reference to
cooking
in the first part of the sentence so
it's like that was just a weird verb
okay but like maybe she's writing a
cookbook called starting over
i would buy it yeah and that would taste
good okay read it one more time
they say it's never too late to start
over i say starting over never tasted so
good
they're like two halves of a sentence
put together because it should have been
they say starting over tastes bad just
so the tasting
would make sense yeah no i agree it's
like it was cut and pasted from a
different tag
okay i'm glad you agree margaret
joseph's our queen this is just the one
about queens
i renovate elevate and sometimes i
instigate
that's good because she is her house is
totally renovated and i actually
started to look forward to mondays she
does this um
series on her instagram story where she
updates everyone on the house like
and they're moving so fast i know
everyone was like joking that she's like
waited 11 years to actually renovate her
house
but it is so interesting to watch and
she has such interesting style
and joe like does it all and i'm living
for it on her instagram
love it melissa gorga i can tell you're
green with envy and honey green is not
your color
it's cute yeah it's cute dolores
i'm loyal and i'm lovable but don't you
dare call me gullible
i love a rhyme yeah is that something
from last season someone called her
gullible right
yeah i forget what she was about last
season but i wasn't about her
she was about saying that jackie was not
cut from the same cloth as them oh that
was so weird that was really bizarre
which
leads into jackie's tag which is the
best one i may be cut from a different
cloth
but it's top quality fabric love the
reference to last season
okay i love the first half but like i
feel like the second half could have
been better
i love the message yeah i love the
message but it's like the punch line of
like it's
top quality fabric like there has to be
a better way of saying that
yeah like a better cuter way okay as
opposed to being like a fabric salesman
no she sounds like she works in the
garment district
i have great top quality fabric
jennifer aiden whoever says money can't
buy happiness
clearly doesn't have my credit limit
that's very good ten out of ten
ten out of ten classic housewives like
love to see it love
very very good yeah i'm really excited
for this season
me too um i'm just i'm ready for
something fresh
i feel like i've become just like very
monotonous in my content everyone's
suffering you know the
repercussions of kovid and i'm just
looking for something new
mm-hmm even though this will be like
very coveted because they just filmed it
nothing will be as covety as oc though
nothing ever nothing
except new jersey had started filming
when covet hit it's kind of like on the
exact same timeline as oc
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] but in the
trailer the trailer wasn't super coveted
right
okay yeah okay next fifth and final
story
fans think ariana could ariana i'm sorry
is it the fifth and final story that's
brought to you by hum
yes oh my god this is so crazy that you
said that yeah formula
what are the odds formulated by experts
and rigorously tested each unique hum
nutrition supplement
packs a combo of potent clean and
clinically proven ingredients
designed for specific goals like clear
skin improved skin
hair growth and sorry improved sleep
hair growth balance mood and healthier
body
to help boost your well-being in the
ways you need it to most take their quiz
and get individualized product
recommendations from their team of
registered dietitians
to help bring your skin body hormones
and mood
into balance with hum nutrition we love
a quiz here at the morning toast because
honestly
one product is not one size fits all
like people have different needs
especially with vitamins like i
personally
have a lot of trouble sleeping and i
suffer from fatigue during the day so
it's so helpful to have
vitamins like specifically recommended
for me for my needs that maybe
may not be what you need and that's why
we love a quiz and also hum nutrition
has like the most
wonderful supplements like different
things for what you're looking for
throughout my life i've
like gotten different ones and i feel
like they're great for bloating or when
you ever wanna
i don't know what a better word for that
is but like puffiness
yeah drain yeah i mean honestly one of
our favorite products is the hair sweet
hair which is the vegan gummy
that boosts the body's ability to
maintain healthy vibrant hair and
support hair growth another one is the
daily cleanse which is really good it's
a unique formula of detoxifying herbs
and minerals detoxifying
yes that help reduce breakouts and
improve skin clarity
so whatever your needs are you can find
something specific for you at home
and if you want to get 15 off your first
order use code toast
they have flexible subscription options
and chic packaging so it's insanely easy
to stay
on top of your daily dosage too so again
that's 15
off your first order of 29 or more with
code
toast it's hum nutrition dot com check
it out
tell him jackie o and cloudy sent you
code toast for 15
off love it okay fifth and final story
fans think ariana grande could join the
weekend super bowl halftime show
i think that would be that would be
fabulous yeah fans are thinking hoping
speculating that she will be joining but
it does
make me wonder if he will bring out
anyone and if so
who ari and him have collabed on the
song love me harder which is a super
popular song
so super old yeah but i don't know i
really see both sides of the argument
for bringing someone out versus not
bringing someone out
right no it really did it's case by case
because sometimes i'm so against it like
i really felt like jlo did not need
anyone
no i feel like well she didn't decide to
bring out shakira like the super bowl
told her
that was disrespectful but they also
brought out other artists
bad bunny i think was there yeah during
their set and then when you think of
like katy perry she brought out lenny
kravitz and missy elliott
but then they remember that lady gaga
didn't bring out anyone she's one of my
favorites
i feel like i don't know i kind of would
always make the argument like don't
bring anyone out like this is a once in
a lifetime opportunity like show us
everything that you have
because i loved how lady gaga did it i
really did but what i'm thinking is like
i think it's
i don't think i i can't make a general
consensus on whether super bowl
i think it's each person i don't think
lady gaga should have brought anyone out
i don't think beyonce needs to bring
anyone out i i think the weeknd could
benefit from some supplemental
you know features yeah but i just feel
like him bringing out ariana grande
who's like
a major pop star is
doesn't really make sense because like
she could be doing her own halftime show
i don't think it's going to be ariana
right well that would
kind of eclipse him who has he
collaborated with
besides to see the song with pose malone
or did i make that up that
would be fast but that's another one
where it's like he's so big
too it's not a feature when it's like
two big superstars
i guess yeah hold on i'm gonna go to his
song collabs because i do think he'll
bring someone out but i don't think it's
these people that were that we've
mentioned so far i mean i think that the
weekend is a great performer in the
sense that like he actually has an
incredible voice
and there's so many people who you know
you hear on the radio and then you see
them perform and it's just not matching
up like
they're not nearly as vocally talented
and so i think the weekend will
will deliver in that sense
but he's kind of low-key you know when
the super bowl is very like katy perry
was like on a
elephant like it's very over the top i
don't know how that's gonna work because
i don't see him as an over-the-top
performer i see him as just like you
know very low-key
and fabulous yeah okay i'm looking at
all of
here are his songs that other people
have collabed on the zone featuring
drake
live for featuring drake i mean drake
would be so crazy
but i feel like that's another the same
thing love me harder with ariana grande
he doesn't have a ton of collabs
he has another song with aria new album
okay wait we'll check it out
pray for me with kendrick lamar that
would be cool powers power with suzanne
travis scott
oh by the way scizza is a perfect person
to come out because
first of all her new song good day mama
it's so good and like everyone on tik
tok is obsessed with it
and she's still like technically a new
artist i think like
she's still considered like burgeoning
yes and i actually think that would be
an amazing collab
yeah maybe they would sing her song i
love that new song
over now with calvin harris i guess it
also has to be a song that like people
like and know also i don't know how you
would collab on stage with calvin harris
because he's a dj so he would like come
up and just like
plug in his ipod
that's so funny but then also like
elastic heart which is sia featuring the
weeknd
and diplo oh oh that would be cool yeah
that would be cool like a song that he
has sang on someone else's
yeah i don't know none of these except
for the sizzle one none of these are
like tickling my fancy like maybe
he is best on his own yeah no but i
always think like bringing someone out
it's exciting because it's like who's
gonna come out
um but it has to be the right person
yeah one of my all-time favorite weekend
activities is just sitting on youtube
and watching
old performances of people seeing the
national anthem at the super bowl
and um they're half time shows katy
perry's is great lady gaga's is great i
love i could watch whitney houston sing
the national anthem
47 000 times same as beyonce so good
um it's just a fabulous activity bruno
mars halftime show is amazing beyonce
half-time show was amazing yes the one
where bruno mars and beyonce then bring
out coldplay no no cold fly brings out
bruno mars and beyonce like
chris martin is so weird yes so weird
borderline ruined it yeah even though
it's his show no but it's like leave
beyonce and bruno
i could watch also any bruno mars any
concert like
the energy the talent where is he i know
he's just like
enjoying his life right now and i feel
like he's gonna come back bigger and
better than ever
also like the one here are some that
happen in recent memory that i just have
like blocked out
justin timberlake blocked out goodbye
even marine time no thank you no they're
like good but it was
it was on the heels of like them
literally like performing those songs
like
every at every award show they were just
like so kind of like worn out
yeah it was just not it no it was not it
whatsoever
so i'm really excited super bowl is next
sunday our prediction is still not in so
wait to place your bets i mean when i
found out that the super bowl was not
this sunday i was genuinely surprised
like i just have been thinking it was
this sunday like
forever no i knew it was next sunday but
we were just like talking about it as if
it was so imminent
yeah so we have time i'm still not sure
on where i land is it the old guard or
the new guard
i don't know i think i'm gonna bet on
the bucks well now everyone's betting on
the box and i know they are
that's right i have to be the contrarian
so yeah i know and i love to like an
underdog moment
yeah no i mean that was just that would
go against everything i stand for on
this show if i just went with what's
popular
right and super bowls are like where
like you know boys become men and like
the underdogs like
something amazing always happens at the
studio not always there i feel like
recently some of the games have been
really boring
well remember that one that we watched
that was so boring when there's like not
even a chance like the losers are gonna
win no but like that's still a good game
like there was
one recently where like nobody scored
for so long it was so bad like no one
was making iconic plays
oh i'm sorry are you hearing about this
drama on the stock market
yes okay i don't know enough about it to
talk about it but from what i understand
like a bunch of people on reddit just
like completely upended the stock market
input good for them and made gamestop a
fortune 500 company
gamestop and amc theaters and they made
them both really big and
and so right now so so gamestop like
they they just
and gamestop is like the game store made
by video games right it's like an
archaic business like they they should
not be like where they're at
so they decided to do with amc theaters
and i literally heard about on tic tac
and you know my ass bought 200
of amc stock yesterday on robin hood and
literally this morning it so much drama
had happened and
i'm sure people who work in finance are
going to be like i'm saying it wrong but
what had happened was
there was so much drama like everyone
was like very volatile market
robin hood is not letting people trade
today i open my app i read
gamestop i open my app and it won't it
says error
whoa they put out a tweet that they're
not letting people trade certain stocks
but my app won't even open whoa
maybe it's like just crash because
everybody's going robin hood to do these
things
and i don't understand like how it
is but i just think it's hilarious that
like people on the internet are like
making influencing like these huge
streets yeah i think it's hysterical and
i just think everyone got together and
was like let's
we're a lot of people like let's make
this company really big and they did it
and it's
so funny it's crazy i don't
know enough about it to like understand
the implications
but what are the long-term implications
here i don't know but just like on its
face it's hysterical
and if i lose my 200 i'm gonna be so
upset yeah
i think i got in a little too late like
i don't know
well good luck to you and if somebody
wants to explain it
feel free to drop a comment on our
instagram yeah i still probably won't
understand it
ben was explaining it to me and i just
like could not get it
yeah i don't really think he got it
either um that's our show anything you
want to tap
into before we wrap it up no i mean i'm
going to try and watch
uh catch up on some housewives today so
we'll see if that happens redheads is
coming out this afternoon
definitely listen if you've read the
book um if you're reading the book save
up for it and you know it's never too
late to become a redhead and i just feel
like that's the most important takeaway
from the episode
and look at you like you became a
redhead and it wasn't too late
no it was not i was worried though when
i got here i'm like oh my god is it too
late anybody said no
never uh once again my book is available
at girl no job.com
book anywhere you can get books ebooks
and audiobooks you can find my book
girl with no job crazy oh continue
beautiful life of an instagram their
sponsor and her vlog of pub day will be
up today at patreon.com
the morning toast so content just out
the ass today so much content like if
you stack your day right
you could be busy watching content like
until the work day is over
and that's the most important and that's
really why we do what we do
to distract you from your workplace
productivity you're right you're right
thank you so much for listening to the
morning show stop millennial morning
show
where we deliver we are the millennial
morning show we
thank you so much for listening to the
melania morning show where we deliver
the fast side stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cats box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we hope you have an amazing day
enjoy the fabulousness that is the day
before thursday friday
and we hope you have a great day next
time we see you it's gonna be friday
guys it's going to be amazing and you
know what we got to do
we got it to get down on friday what did
you say
i said got to when you said gotta we got
to get down must
[Music]
be
you